-Here at "Late Night,"
every night I deliver
a monologue made up
of jokes written by
a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight White male,
would be difficult
for me to deliver.
We don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them,
so we'd like to share them
with you now
in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Tape rips ]
These are two of our writers,
Amber and Jenny.
-I'm Black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not.
So here's how it works.
I'll read the setups
to these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
A queer website recently
published an article titled
"Ten Lesbian Books
You Need to Read this Fall."
-A lesbian book is like
a straight book,
except it has a climax.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-16 Black candidates
are major party nominees
for Senate
and governor this fall.
-So do those candidates,
I say get ready to be
called each others names.
[ Laughter ]
-Andrew, do you ever
get mistaken for anyone?
-Yeah.
Laurence Fishburne.
-Oh.
-Hmm.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
According to the
American Medical Association,
lesbian medical students
may have higher rates of burnout
than straight students.
-Because it's tough to do
all that studying
and take care of five dogs.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Jenny,
why do lesbians like dogs?
-Because they love relationships
that last 15 to 17 years.
[ Laughter ]
-"Lord of the Rings" fans
have expressed anger
that the new spinoff,
based on the books,
features Black hobbits.
-A Black hobbit
is like a White hobbit,
except your girlfriend
wants to [bleep] it.
[ Laughter ]
-But why?
-Because it's 6'2."
[ Laughter ]
-A forklift driver is hoping
to be the UK's first lesbian
Miss Great Britain.
-Officials suspected
she was a lesbian
when her talent
was operating a forklift.
[ Laughter ]
-A man from Philadelphia
walked more than
400 miles along
the Underground Railroad
to celebrate Harriet Tubman's
200th birthday.
-Said Harriet Tubman,
"I did that so you
wouldn't have to."
[ Laughter ]
Amber, what did you do
to celebrate
Harriet Tubman's birthday?
-I did just what she would
want me to do,
not a goddamn thing.
-Do you really think
that's what she'd want?
-Yes. Take it from me,
Laurence Fishburne.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The White House
recently hosted a roundtable
with a group of lesbian leaders.
-"Oh, [bleep].
My ex is here,"
said all of them.
-During a recent briefing,
White House Press Secretary
Karine Jean-Pierre
mistakenly referred
to Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas
as Justice Thompson.
-She meant to say
Uncle Thompson.
-The website Autostraddle
recently published
an article titled
"How to Dress Like
the Main Character
in a Lesbian Rom Com."
-The article is just one photo.
-Oh, come on.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The flannel fits.
[ Laughter ]
-Jenny. Hey, Jenny?
-Mm-hmm.
-What's the difference
between a lesbian rom com
and a straight rom com?
-In straight rom coms,
everyone survives.
-Hey, guys.
Jenny Hagel here.
I don't know if you know this,
but in lesbian movies
and TV shows, the lesbians
always die, every time.
[ Whispering ] I might not live
to the end of this segment.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey. Hey, Seth?
Why don't you tell one?
No, guys, I could not.
-Oh, come on.
-I just don't feel like
if I tell one
it'll end well.
-Please, do one?
-Come on, do one.
-I trust you both. You're my
friends, and I trust you.
A Massachusetts woman
is raising money
to open a new lesbian bar
in Boston.
Because if there's one place
lesbians love to go,
it's Beantown.
-Seth!
Gross!
-I barely get it.
[ Laughter ]
We're at work right now.
-I'm tried to go once.
I got super lost.
-[ Laughs ]
-No man knows
how to locate Beantown.
[ Laughter ]
-But Google Maps
just told me to go home.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, you know what?
I'll try again.
-You will?
-Against my better judgment.
-Okay.
-Disney's upcoming live action
version of "The Little Mermaid"
will feature
a black actress playing Ariel.
She'll be breaking barriers
as the first
Black woman who can swim.
-[ Gasps ]
How dare you?
-Stop acting like
you didn't write this!
-I am shocked!
You should be
ashamed of yourself!
Black women
and lesbians are liars!
♪♪
[ Tape rips ]
Oh, no!
-[ Gasping ]
-Oh, no!
-My friend, my gay, gay friend!
[ Sobbing ]
-Oh, and for the best.
It's for the best.
Amber Ruffin and Jenny Hagel,
everybody.
-I'm okay.
-Hey, you guys.
This is very important.
Watch these two
on "The Amber Ruffin Show,"
which returns
for a season three next Friday,
September 30th on Peacock
with Guess Hillary
and Chelsea Clinton.
We'll be right back
Ana de Armas, everybody.